[Music]
we all need wedding cakes must be three
lucky men who's got a picture you guys
realize that's the same guy right oh
don't be silly
[Music]
son aren't you tired of being hated by
every man in the lab I do like being
adored by the ladies though no lady who
gazes into the eyes of the prince will
be able to resist his smile on his 21st
birthday this bluffing curse will be
doesn't three days Prince Charming it is
time to choose your one true love and
liberate all others from your spell
piece of cake
excuse me now and save us all there's
nothing I fear only with every other
lady in the land Wow well that was
different so determine which of these
three princesses is my true true love
the fate of my entire kingdom depends on
it your kingdoms in luck because I can
take you to that we leave at once oh hey
I feel so alive what is your plan
true true love must be earned by running
the gums of three impossible tasks
across passable paths
to survive and unsurvivable attack we're
dead
hello there you tell a cat little
flowers let's do this
[Applause]
well that played out differently in my
mind
[Music]
you
you